you know we're so concerned about having
this high LDL and high cholesterol but
we rarely look on the flip side and what
are the dangers of having low LDL or low
cholesterol I think you're going to be
very surprised to find out that there's
just as many if not more problems with
low LDL and low cholesterol than there
are with high LDL or high cholesterol
I'm going to give you a couple things
that are facts number one your body
makes the great majority of all the
cholesterol 25 of your brain is
cholesterol in fact your brain cells
make cholesterol cholesterol is needed
to make vitamin D cholesterol is needed
to make bile salts to help you digest
fats and absorb vitamin A d e and K and
omega-3 fatty acids cholesterol is
intimately involved in making your cell
membranes so when your cholesterol goes
too low okay and your LDL goes too low
there are all sorts of bad things that
can happen now when I'm talking about
cholesterol I'm talking about
cholesterol that is less than 120mm
grams per deciliter 3.1 millimoles per
liter and when we're talking about LDL
I'm talking about values less than 50
milligrams per deciliter or 1.3
millimoles per liter when your LDL or
total cholesterol goes below those
numbers you are at risk for quite a few
things number one cataracts which is
pretty wild number two fatty liver
disease yeah you would think the fatty
liver actually would be caused by
consuming too much cholesterol now it's
actually not true now the next problem
is you're not going to make enough bile
okay because bile is made from
cholesterol and there's a whole bunch of
problems that are connected to that a
fatty stool so your stool will float
indicating you're not breaking down fats
so you're more than likely to develop a
vitamin A deficiency a vitamin D
deficiency a vitamin E deficiency
vitamin K1 vitamin K2 deficiency as well
as an omega-3 fatty acid deficiency
which can all give give you massive
problems down the road and another
symptom would be constipation why
because bile salts help to lubricate the
gastrointestinal tract another big side
effect of not having enough LDL or
cholesterol is something called
intellectual disability okay your role
intelligence goes down
you also have mood disorders like
anxiety and depression your risk for
cancer goes up your immune system
suffers now that could be potentially
because you're not making enough vitamin
D you may even develop something called
hyperthyroidism where your thyroid is
working too fast so anytime this topic
of cholesterol comes up you need to look
at both sides and in this next video I
think you'll be quite surprised to find
out there's not a lot of problems
associated with high cholesterol mainly
on the low side and I put that video up
right here check it out